[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages time to see what's
making the headlines with the daily
mails consultant editor andrew pearce
and the daily mirrors associate editor
kev mcguire welcome and great to see
both of you on another busy day has to
be said so let's uh kick off with the
front pages then as ever and remarking
on the decision to drop plan b covert
restrictions in england the metro
splashes with return to the office
turning to westminster and the ongoing
fallout from parties in downey street
the eye declares johnson clings onto
power for now
the telegraph understands he won't
resign even if a no-confidence vote is
called
the son takes the so-called pork pie
plot to the next level
the star says the prime minister is
still refusing to do the right thing
according to the paper and resign
at the local level the bury times
reports on the defection of their mp
christian wakeford from the tories to
labour
the financial times suggest mr
wakeford's crossing the floor has
actually had the effect of rallying
conservative mps to the prime minister's
side
conversely the guardian quotes the
former cabinet minister david davis
telling mr johnson in the name of god go
well the express says allies of mr
johnson are rallying to his defense
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code that you'll see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
or them to be fair uh andrew pearson
kevin let's bring you in then well what
a day as their speaker said andrew um i
suppose let's start with the pm is he
more or less secure after what we saw
today
well it was the most extraordinary day
of high drama it really was and um
that's why politics is so unpredictable
that we thought there was going to be an
awful lot of letters going in from this
2019 intake the so-called pork pie
plotters uh it didn't happen they didn't
materialize
and then ironically i think the
defection i think the ft's got it right
the defection of christian uh wakeford
as he's been nicknamed by his formatory
colleagues um backfired in a sense that
okay it was it was a good bit of theater
for the labour party but actually um it
reminded tory mps who the enemy is not
boris johnson the labour party uh and it
got and it galvanized opinion on the
prime minister's side uh so um uh and
he's not particularly he's not
particularly popular this mp anyway and
actually defections they're just
horrible aren't they because it's it's
it's it's treachery you're
all the people who've worked so hard to
get you elected the people in your
constituency office and that's how you
you treat them you betray them uh and
he's betrayed the voters who supported
him too in the in the general election
just two years ago and um it won't end
well um uh and i imagine some of his
colleagues such as angela rainer are
going to take a rather dim view of some
of the things he said about her and the
labour party just a few weeks ago when
he was still
happily in the bosom of the tory party
well the guardians picked up on that and
also that really dramatic moment that
david davis stood up and quoted we were
all told uh leo amory uh talking to
chamberlain in the norway debate just
before he was replaced by churchill uh
was something of course that boris
johnson knows only to well because he
wrote a book on churchill although he
then said he didn't know what he was
referring to of course but that was real
her drama wasn't it in the commons uh
kevin
oh oh it was and i i think it edged the
defection of christian waifu and and
incidentally i always believe mps who
defect from a party should automatically
have to fight a by-election but david
davis so does he apparently didn't he
co-sign
co sign a bill on that but anyway do you
continue yeah
yeah well well if we talk about
christian wakeford he says like i'm a
centrist politician he's really saying
he's not changed he labor has changed
got nearer him while johnson the
conservatives are going further away on
universal credit cuts and free school
meals we could
discuss it endlessly but i i thought the
moment was david davis incredibly
powerful
intervention by him given that he's been
a boris johnson supporter in the past
he's incredibly independent-minded
uh david davis i think he's a
he's a conservative principal there's
been many issues i've agreed
uh with him on including june the labor
era when he was against extending um
detention without charge to 90 days uh
his is very principled but for him to
stand up like that see he will be
reflecting what a lot of other
conservatives actually think privately
but wouldn't say quite so publicly or as
robustly as he did we don't know how
many letters have gone in
clearly it's not 54 yet
um i suppose christian wakeford is now
taken out probably doesn't count um but
the prime minister might have survived
the day but this is this is what we're
talking about we're talking about him
surviving a day and somehow that is is
wonderful i think he's kind of like the
condemned man on his way to the scaffold
who's just stopped to take a little look
at the sunshine before he's he's walked
on again i think he's all these
fundamental problems are absolutely
still there
we are old enough uh sadly to to
remember that in any leadership contest
david davis would normally throw his
name into the ring but maybe no more um
let's go to the daily telegraph then
andrew and the idea here
with the quote that johnson says i won't
quit if rebels force a vote he only
needs a simple majority we just remind
ourselves what happened with theresa may
don't we he just needs to get halfway
exactly theresa may um uh
thought the leadership but then there
was a confidence vote against her she
she she contested it she won uh she
didn't have an enormous majority but she
had enough and she slipped on and i
think she survived for another six
months boris will um i think if there
was a confidence vote next week and i
don't think there will be by the way uh
we're expecting the sue grey report
around wednesday next week i think
possibly thursday it might slip
i think my own hunch is from talking to
mps talking to ministers um he's been
shored up in the last 24 hours
perversely i think he'll go through i
think then that there'll be a an
assessment when we see what happens with
the local elections but don't
underestimate how popular what he's
announced today getting rid of plan b
is that's going to make a big difference
to gory tory mood and morale it's going
to make cheer people up throughout the
country
and it's a sign we are finally relent
getting out of this wretched pandemic
and we're coming out of it a lot quicker
than a lot of countries in europe so um
i think he'll be there right through to
the local elections that's my hunch uh
and then who knows after that and as
we've said before about
mean you mean the foreign
elections not the next generation
elections right
sorry may local elections yeah and no no
sorry forgive me
and we've people have written off boris
before and they said it's all over i
wouldn't write him off at at all i think
he's a great survivor he's a great
escapologist uh and um uh that the the
red meat that he's announced you know
operation red meat has gone down pretty
well with some backbenchers uh so
they're still fighting him and actually
bizarrely today in house of commons i
like that appalling interview with beth
rigby yesterday which was the trigger
for david davis's intervention because
he thought it was so awful i thought he
performed very well in the conference
today
it's interesting though uh anna that uh
andrew said it's gone down well with
tory back benches that's what it's all
about he's now fighting the tory civil
war it's all about the country as a
whole we know for instance this idea of
having the military somehow stemming the
flow of small boats was just pr one the
royal navy had been uh involved for uh
for several years and two what does he
expect them to do shell france torpedo
dinghies
they'll be rescuing people in boats
that's what sailors do when they're at
sea they see somebody in peril they they
rescued him it's all about fighting i
thought he'd go by the end of the year
because we saw inflation is up to 5.4
percent
energy bills are going to go through the
roof not entirely his fault although he
could do more to bring them down or
bring that increase down he's going to
put up national insurance in april when
the prices are going to be far outpacing
average earnings so livingston is going
to be squeezed then he'll have the may
the main elections um and this is before
we even consider sue grier's report
which may be the end of next week and i
think that something just changed in the
mood the political mood i think it
started with these ridiculous and uh
suicidal defense of owen patterson and
sleaze it's gone on through hiding the
truth about parties and the telegraph
says well if there's a vote he'll uh
fight on well who thought he wasn't
gonna fight on the telegraph had a great
story about the parties in downing
street on the eve of the
the duke of edinburgh's uh funeral
incredible breathtaking
revelation that but he won't quit the
rebels force but of course he won't quit
and even if he if he wins it he could be
mortally wounded because yes theresa may
did win as i think from memory the vote
was 200 to
111 but there was a revolt in the
conservative association none of the
problems were were fixed and she was
gone and
she survived the vote in the december
she was gone the following july boris
johnson whatever
he's gone coming back
you've brought up the cost of living and
you know many people suggesting that the
tory party is fixated on parties at the
moment and masks or in fact i suppose
the nation is when actually we're all
going to lose effectively 10 of our
income come april it's going to be
extraordinary what happens then to
people's incomes and the focus needs to
be so someone ann whitaker for example
came up today said now is not the time
to get rid of a leader now is the time
to buckle up and sort this out the ft2
andrew suggesting he's bought more time
and certainly a number of the 2019ers as
they called themselves came out to speak
to our deputy political editor in the
lobby really backing boris johnson today
i mean was that also coordinated a bit
like the you know 20 or so
plotters well it isn't once
but hang on i think boris johnson's team
have fought back uh i think they were
asleep at the wheel yesterday when um he
gave that pretty poor interview to beth
rigby but they've come out fighting
today he was much better in the comments
today uh the the defection actually pure
theater for labor but nobody likes
defectors a lot of there'll be a lot of
labour mps on those labour benches won't
like the idea of that bloke being on
their side i can tell you uh so i think
he i think you've got to give credit
where it's due the prime minister had a
better day today and um and people i
talked to said some tory mps actually
took their letters back from the
chairman of the 1922 when they saw the
defense we were told that as well have
you got i mean has anybody actually
confirmed any names or numbers on that
no no because
grain brady never tells anybody anything
he never leaks unfortunately no no but
it is tory whips and loyalist mps
asserting what is not has not been
proved until somebody is produced who
says i'm a conservative mp i put in my
letter i have now withdrawn it i won't
believe it it's just false propaganda
another smoke screen another intent
kevin you don't know that
you don't know that you don't name
somebody i heard it
sources
did they name anybody to you no they
didn't
why don't be gullible don't swallow it
until you get somebody it is just
another tactic to show well
if you produce something can you produce
somebody we were telling technology
we were we were told 20 20 of the 2019
people were going to put in letters
today they didn't do it so there's a lot
of black propaganda on both sides i
think probably some tory mps did
withdraw their letters because they did
not like that defection one bit okay you
can't name one on that very defection
let's just show people the uh berry
times as we move through into the break
mp rocks boris by switching sides the
mask certainly drew a rather a snidey
tweet from nadine doris and uh momentum
and young labour both not entirely being
enthusiastic about that but we will uh
save that for after the break if you
don't mind kevin
okay okay
i was waiting for him to say something
as you could tell anyway uh coming up uh
we've talked about it already but a
return to covet plan a is it the right
move more in just a moment
[Music]
welcome back to watching the press
preview with me now and
news of course is the covert
restrictions uh signified today by both
boys johnson and the health secretary
that they will go large parts of them
kevin uh including as the metro points
out return to the office because these
are one of the newspapers that get
picked up by the office workers yeah no
absolutely the matter will be pleased
about that people going to to work on a
day that 359 deaths were announced the
end of uh covered restrictions in
england were also announced british
medical association warning
that covert could rebat could rebound
and come back rather fiercely because of
this but most people have been going to
work as as usual anyway it's because uh
even at the height of the first lockdown
when number 10 was a party central i
think it was only one in four people
were working from home uh and if you
drive if you're driving a bus a taxi or
lorry work in a factory a warehouse
you're in a shop
whatever you'd be going to work but
office workers going back uh that will
boost city centres although
some towns and smaller villages might
lose out because the people who've been
spending their money locally will now be
selling it more
centrally but it is it's a gamble it
might it might be another gamble that
pays off with 170 000 dead let's hope
that total doesn't keep mounting by 359
every day yeah not universally applauded
uh we saw in the commons those tories
who
wanted restrictions to go seem to be the
ones who stayed behind
but the daily telegraph reporting on
union anger after mosques are scrapped
in classrooms there's been a world
clamour from the education unions to
keep teachers safe
in primary schools obviously no masks
and no vaccine so it's it's harder there
and the running total is what uh seven
day rolling average 93 000 cases twice
roughly what delta was um gamble for you
too andrew
no i think it's a long overdue i'm glad
he did it i'm glad he stuck to his guns
before christmas and didn't go further
than plan b unlike the welsh first
minister who was accusing the prime
minister being reckless and
irresponsible well actually i think um
they're now withdrawing the the extra
restrictions in wales look i'm sorry the
unions are upset in schools but the fact
is we know that omicron is largely it
manifests itself as a cold and often a
mild cold you don't need to close down
schools for a mild cold and if teachers
want to carry on wearing masks they can
i don't understand all this handwringer
oh what about mars look wear a mask if
you want to you don't need the
government to keep telling you what to
do you can work it out yourself i'm
going to carry on wearing a mask on the
tube because i think it's quite it's a
considerate thing to do to other people
and i don't want people sneezing all
over anyway so yeah i'm going to carry
on but i don't need the government to
tell me i have to carry on
you have to uh legally in london uh
andrew uh because it's going to be a
condition of carriage so on the chute
london
well i would have anyway
um
in the next part of my program we'll
talk about self-isolation as well
indicated that too would go at a time
when uh non-vaccinated uh medical staff
in hospitals would lose their jobs which
is which is interesting isn't it but for
the moment andrew pierce kevin thank you
both